-Welcome back, everybody! I'm here with Michael Strahan!
We're about to play shoe golf!
-Okay.
-Now, this is just like regular golf,
but instead of using a club to hit your ball into the hole,
you're gonna use your foot to kick your shoe into a bucket.
And we're gonna play three holes.
Lowest score wins. You ready for this?
-I'm ready. -Alright, let's go, bud.
-But I did notice you wore heavier shoes to get --
-Oh, are you talking about these jams?
-But it's all good. It's all good.
-Alright. We're going to start at hole number one.
Let's hop in. I'll drive.
-Alright. -Yeah.
Thanks again. This is fun. I love to play shoe golf.
Alright. I'm not a good driver.
-What is -- Whoa. -I know.
I was going a little fast here. Hey.
[ Cheers and applause ] Alright, here we go.
-Alright. -I know. I'm a bad driver.
Alright. Good. Now we can get out.
Alright. All the way over here. This is hole number one.
-Okay. -So we have to go down there.
I think there's a gentleman down there waiting with two beers.
Whoever gets the lowest score on this one gets a beer.
-Alright. So who's going to go first?
-You go, bud. -Okay.
-This is the tee box.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
-There's a bunch of deer.
You got to watch out for the deer.
Ooh! [ Laughter ]
Alright. Oops.
-[ Laughs ]
-Alright. Here we go.
-Thank goodness the ceiling panels are metal.
[ Laughter ]
-That one -- I think NBC is mad.
-So you got to make it in the bucket, right?
-Alright. You got to get it in the bucket.
-I've gotta get out of your way. You look --
-Ready? On my way.
-Ohh!
[ Audience ohhs ]
-Almost got the j--
Whoo! Looks like you're away, bud.
-I'm a little away.
-Hee hee hee, hee!
I think I might have it.
Aw. Dang. It's like that.
-Let me get that out of there.
-Yeah, that's the same thing, right? Alright.
[ Laughter ]
-You almost missed it.
-[Irish accent] You guys want a little beer? You worked really hard.
-Thank you very much. I like the terrible accent.
-Oh, it's the best one yet. -Thank you. Here we go.
Alright, so here we have to go through --
There's crocodiles in the water. And there's cactus over there.
-Cacti. -Cactis.
You can go first.
[ Bossa nova music plays ]
♪♪
Not bad. Here we go.
-Whoa! Whoa! -That's a new move.
-That right there is what you call a worm burner.
You didn't mean to do that.
-I didn't mean to do it, but it looked great, though.
Look at that. -If I make this...
-You'll be the shoe-golf champ.
Ooh! That's a little finesse on that one.
But watch this jam right here.
Come on. You know what's up, dude.
-Boo!
-Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a gimme. That's a gimme. That's a gimme.
Alright. Here we go. What are you doing?
-Because I'm everywhere. I'm everywhere.
-What are you doing back here? -You want a freshie.
-No, we're done with your character.
What is going on? Thank you very much.
Who is that guy? -Very good.
-Thank you very much. -So, hold on. I'm down one.
-You got to win this one. This is a windstorm right here.
And there's Hashtag the Panda down there.
Giant wind machine here. There's a lot of birds.
Here we go.
Hey! Dude, the panda hit my shot out of the air.
-Hey, Panda! -Hey, Panda.
-You touch this thing, I'm gonna go Tom Brady on you.
♪♪
-Be careful.
Hashtag, we're just gonna go around you, okay?
Thank you.
-What you doing, Panda?!
-Dude, Panda got you. Dude, not bad.
Good job, bud.
-Fore!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright. Big shot, Jimmy. What you got? Big shot!
-Ohh!
♪♪
-[ Laughs ] I think I know how this is going to end.
I think I know how this is going to end.
That almost went in there. -I'll be honest with you, man.
This is not the music I listen to when I play golf.
[ Laughter ]
-It's the music I listen to.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dinging ]
♪♪
-Hey, I thought the winner
was supposed to drink the beer out of the shoe.
-That's what I thought, too, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ] That's what I --
♪♪
-Did I just win? -Yeah, you just won.
-Yeah. -I forfeited.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yes! Yes! -My thanks to Michael Strahan!
Check out "100,000 Pyramid" Saturdays at 9:00 p.m. on ABC.
We're talking to Jamie Campbell Bower after the break...